you're a helicopter pilot i didn't know
that you're a helicopter pilot i've yes
do you have a helicopter yes
so does that i have a little jeff dunham
are you friends with jeff dunham a
little two-seater uh i know i met jeff a
long time ago but i i have a mc he built
a helicopter dude that guy is a genius
do you ever see that there was a whole
thing on that guy where he like do you
know if if you're a ventriloquist and
you buy a puppet from a store if you get
famous the maker of the puppet can
garnish your wages say like well you got
famous using our thing no yeah so he had
to make design
his own puppet and he was able to do
that like he he has like the artistic
ability to draw and they were shown him
and he was like making this 3d image on
the computer that then went to like look
like a like a house safe or something
like that that built the mold of it and
then he paints it i mean no i see it
that that guy puts in
and he builds his own helicopters and
helicopters and puppets builder genius
he really is he's a [ __ ] jamie yeah
and he's a good guy too
yeah helicopter and puppet builder and
the thing is he took me up in his
helicopter the helicopter makes no sound
he goes
as we're flying he fills in the sound
eventually it makes no sound
i was trying to joke that was a bad joke
just like the puppets don't talk but he
puts the voice in the helicopter no i
missed it
i immediately went to i got a little bit
of tinnitus in this ear and i'm like
wait a minute does he have some sort of
super quiet engine or something you know
you have tinnitus yeah that would drive
me nuts does that drive you nuts that's
that when you hear a ringing in your ear
all the time right yeah do you answer it
do you ever answer that oh boy
you know let me just say this okay do
you do you answer fixed in stones will
break my bones but names will never hurt
me and i have it on good authority that
i can say that that guy who wrote that
is a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
so
have you had any close calls when it
comes to helicopters
no no no it's very safe it's as safe
as my instructor told me flying is as
safe as you are
you can be an idiot
which kobe's pilot was an idiot right
well i'm not going to trash somebody
that's got 15 000 more hours than i do
the report's yet to come out i don't
know what happened but like i just for
me
if i want to uh you know if i'm going to
solo i just uh
you know i just look they have like a
little it's called a metar you just look
at the weather and you know the
visibility a metar yeah are you
pronouncing that rock is it not meter no
it's metar it's called metar it's an an
acronym
meteorological blah blah blah
i know what a centaur is i don't know
what a meter so but and you own your own
two-seater do you take your wife into it
do you take your kids i have never taken
a passenger
yet every time i fly enough where i get
the confidence to do it which i could do
it now i'm just extra extra extra extra
careful so um so where do you go
uh
i just you know whatever i want to go
you just go fly around a lot of these
little airports have um
like really cool restaurants and stuff
like that you can just land get
something to eat so you just go from
airport to airport like did you
because we have you did you didn't fly
here today
no i didn't have you ever flown to a gig
yeah and just
really yeah
but i mean that was [ __ ] cool it was
so cool i've flown to vegas a couple of
times and like what i do is i i rent a
bigger one because mine would take
forever to get there
um so i rent like uh i rented like a
r-44 which is like a four-seater and we
flew there and the approach that when
you come in to where you land yeah is
you fly right by the new york new york
the aladdin the mgm and the other one
there the trop
so you go right and you're like and
you're coming in and you're descending
so you're like
at that level um all right so that's the
helicopter i ended up buying those are
the guys up in vancouver that's a
cadbury g2 which is well you bought a
canadian uh
no it's a french helicopter but i was up
there and uh we had a great time even
you're flying that one right there is
that you flying it uh no no no oh well
let me see who's why is one one person
wearing a helmet but then it's joe rogan
yeah we took him up in a 44 one time you
said you never had a passenger no but no
i i've never s just i'm command and
there's nobody else there oh got it so
so you're flying it
that one yeah i was flying that one and
then my instructor took the picture
obviously
that's
how long have you been flying
since uh like 2014 what does it what
does a helicopter cost
no yeah they're not they're not cheap
they're not cheap
are you asking because you want one dad
well i mean they could be anywhere from
you know like a buck 80
all the way up to millions and millions
and millions and millions of dollars so
like that yeah aviation it's just like
you know there's a reason i only have
the little two-seater egg beater because
you know you know what i want to get i
want to get one of those where you can
land it in a lake and suck up the water
and then drop if my house is ever on
fire i'd like one of those
helicopters where the hoes go you know
what i'm talking about well that's
that's how i got into
that's how i got into uh
flying helicopters
was i was reading conspiracy theory and
about the dollar collapsing
about what the dollar collapsing and all
that and then just being in l.a
thinking about how hard it was to get
out of la even when every when
everything was working it takes forever
and i was like how would i ever get out
of here and just up and out right so
then i was like going ah you know
and then i just started you know it
wasn't 100 conspiracy thing then i just
started i always liked it was an escape
but it was something i always liked and
i always found like i'm sort of a closet
gearhead who doesn't really know how to
fix anything but i will watch people
like one of my favorite guys to watch on
youtube is this guy eric the car guy
because he fixes
like modern cars
which are just a total mystery like back
in the day you know the cars we grew up
with you opened the hood you could still
see the driveway yeah i drove a tesla i
opened the hood and i can see my
shirt that i wore yeah
so
but this guy you know the front wheel
drives it turns sideways the whole
engine is covered in some sort of oh
there's always these plastic things and
just watching him do this stuff
um i'm fascinated to watch so do you
work on your own helicopter
do i no god no no no you find a freedom
flying that you otherwise don't i mean
is that one of the reasons that he said
it was to escape but he sounds like my
husband with the conspiracy theories and
the planning to have an escape route but
i love that oh you know and you know
what when this pandemic and then there
was all those runs on the uh on the
grocery stores where everybody acted
like you know cows had coven there was
gonna be no beef ever again remember
that and the shells are all empty okay i
was so happy for all of those guys that
were getting [ __ ] for having that extra
freezer with the thousand pounds of meat
in there and you know right and all the
toilet paper and the provisions like
they they must have felt like huh honey
huh look at this
what do you want
all the neighbors that's freaking out
and i'm what do you want you want veal
you want pork chop what do you want
that's on the first do you see the first
episode of kirby enthusiasm where he he
found out that albert brooks i'm this is
a spoiler if you haven't watched it so
you can turn this off right now but he
found out that he's a uh a covet hoarder
that's what he called him
he opened the closet and he found all
this he's a covet hoarder a [ __ ]
idiot is a covet hoarder we hate covet
hoarding yeah but i thought you were
going to say like if you
wanted to get your helicopter pilot's
license for an escape route the fact
that you just purchased it purchased a
two-seater is what
well i'm working my way up you know and
then i can make which child will you
choose to escape with when you it's like
sophie's choice yeah
look it started with a crazy idea and it
ended up in a great thing where you get
like i'll tell you la has some of the
most beautiful houses
you're ever going to see and like you
can see them you know and so many of
them behind like gates and stuff like
that so you can fly over
and see them like i i uh one of my
favorite ones when i fly over this
there's this home that uh was in the
godfather that they i think the horses
had
seen was shot there
uh jfk and uh jackie kennedy had their
um
their honeymoon there where is it what
part of l.a is it um beverly hills
yeah that sort of area it's this
beautiful house and then it has like
these three like look like
infinity pools but the old school ones
where they're just for decoration and
then there's the real pool like this
that old school
like hollywood um and you just hover
over people's homes no no i just fly by
i don't do that no because there's also
like noise abatement and stuff so you
got to make sure you're high enough
above the ground people get like you do
photography
no no because it'd be great to take like
aerial shots well the thing about a
helicopter is you always have to hang on
to stuff or else it
flies is a helicopter dangerous much
more is it is it more dangerous than a
plane
it's one of those it's an argument that
people that know what are way better way
more about aviation than i do argue all
the time there's there's things that
like uh
it's easy to tip well listen if if the
if you're playing it seems like you got
one rotor like if your engine goes it
seems like you just dropped you have to
catch yeah and you catch your rpms if
you don't catch your rpms you're screwed
the thing about it how many times have i
told you that i know it's important i do
that anyway but if you fly in a plane
the engine quits you're still flying
right so that's their thing and then
also with them they also have like the
parachute
they can push a button now like you know
and just do that but the thing about
that thing is is you know my friend
bought a plane that that you're talking
about in a place yeah but now you don't
have any control of where you're going
to land and where you're going to go so
dude i mean there could be people in a
food court you're this you're hanging
like you're just like going [ __ ]
this thing is coming down but the
chances of you surviving on the end of a
parachute and living with the deaths of
all those children you land on the so i
mean there's there's arguments for both
the thing with what they uh i don't want
to bore you with this but with like it's
not boring okay so with the helicopter
what gives you this lift when the
engine's running is you're drawing air
into the main rotor is what you're doing
and those blades all they're doing
they're just shaped the same way as a
wing right so it's the same thing you
getting low pressure high pressure
underneath high pressure goes directly
to low pressure takes the immediate
direct route and it says you're talking
too fast slow down that's what brings
you up so that's why you're able to
hover because where they need to be
going like 60 knots to get the lift that
thing is spinning to that point and
that's when you get light on the skids
and then you're up so you're drawing air
into the disc so when you have an engine
failure how you keep that going is the
the it descending slash falling back
down to the earth the air is now rushing
up
and it keeps it spinning but the thing
is is when you're if you're if you were
to be flying really fast your blades are
turned like that
so the second the engine stops
the amount of force slowing that down
your your rpms drop really quickly so
the second you hear the rpm you you slam
down the collective and then then you go
af cyclic and then that gets them
spinning and if you don't
if it goes beyond there's a certain
point in every helicopter if they got
lower than that you cannot recover them
and then you are [ __ ] so there is that
do they put you
when they do you go in a simulator and
they simulate these uh problems like i
know when people are getting their
pilot's license
you just you just do them and then but
what i like about a helicopter though
is that where a plane you still have to
be going a certain speed i don't know
much about planes but you still have to
go in a certain speed when you land and
if you're landing and there's like
little tree stumps and stuff you could
cartwheel in that thing or whatever and
like those things there's no crumple
zones they're not designed to hit
anything so that's like being in like
you know a 55 oldsmobile with the
steering wheel is going to go through
your chest and everything but with a
helicopter you come down and and in the
end you you go into your flare and you
bleed off all that forward air speed so
no brain slamming against the skull and
[ __ ] coming into you you bleed all of
that off
and then you you level it off like that
and then your last bit of energy when
you go down you pull up ideally this is
how you do it and that pushes you
cushions your landing but even then even
if you were to have a hard landing you
might mess up your back a little bit but
you're not going to get crushed
you're not going to go spinning and
flying someone who has a fear of flying
this conversation is this is aviation
one on one
it's definitely one-on-one if i'm
talking about it
how long have you been flying since
2014. oh wow
i read a book called and i am really
green i don't know a lot about it but i
i i'm i'm
proficient for how long i've been doing
i used to uh you know i'm afraid of
helicopters now but i used to fly in
helicopters oh they're great it was
great especially when there's traffic
what do you know bill it's really it's
really flying too
that's what i like you give up a lot in
speed you do the coolest thing i ever
did well
my pilot's name was his name was
actually johnny cool
it's not i'm not making it up if if he's
listening i'd be afraid to fly with a
guy named johnny cool because i think
johnny's gonna show up wasn't that his
name rich johnny cool yeah and and
i used to do uh deal or no deal at cbs
television city you know at beverly yeah
at beverly in fairfax i followed your
career you've had an amazing amazing so
he would park the helicopter on the roof
of that building
and then at night i would play the mgm
hotel in las vegas so i would say good
night to the dealer no deal audience run
upstairs get in the helicopter he take
off off the roof this is rush hour so he
would we would fly over he'd land in van
nuys here i'd get in a plane and boom i
was on stage at eight o'clock at night
how great was it when you're flying from
where you were taping
up and over and you see all those brake
lights oh and all those headlights and
it's just like and also just as the crow
flies i just got scared i lost an agent
in a helicopter crash and kobe
uh well he was with um what's the guitar
player that he went down with um um
phil no who's a fam who's a famous
guitar player that that stevie ray
vaughan stevie ray ron he was in the
he's in the helicopter with stevie ray
vaughan wow yeah and so that afternoon
that shouldn't make you afraid of
helicopters because that was like pilot
error
well i asked you about that and i was
asking you about the kobe thing is that
pilot air i don't know well that was
something that it already came about
well that was the thing about that what
i would be nervous is if somebody is
landing off airport meaning you're not
at an airport yeah okay and you're in
like a mountainous hilly area if but he
wasn't landing there if there was poor
visibility
well they hit the side of a hill i don't
think the guy deliberately flew into it
unless he was suicidal but like if you
don't know that area like i do a casino
down in um san diego outside of san
diego
and the thing is is i could fly into
there and they'll let me land right in
the parking lot which is the james bond
thing yeah the thing is is by the time
ladies and gentlemen bill burr yeah
right but the thing is is by the time
the show's over it's dark out and it's
you know you're in like a valley and
there's all those wires the wires will
really kill people and and we just
wouldn't you just go straight up up up
up up and then fly forward
you know in theory you think that that
could work but it's just like just not
knowing where stuff it's just it's just
you know well that's something that you
could do you you you basically you
calculate the risk versus reward and i'm
just like how about i just land at this
airport nearby and i'll drive down and
it'll take an extra half an hour and i
live
[Music]